[Musique]
non mais je rêve je vais dire ces nanas
et cherche les en mer à son image elle
devrait savoir ce qu'elle risque non je
dois ma loge et qu'est ce que tu fais
tout faux bien sûr et ce curieux
qu'est ce que tu fais et j'ai dit qu'est
ce que tu fais
chaque semaine je vais dans un bar et je
fais semblant d'être trop saoul pour
tenir debout
chaque semaine un mec gentil vient voir
si ça va tu es jolie comme un coeur je
suis un mec gentil away on a des
affinités d'accord comment je m'appelle
g quel âge pardon un peu trop dia
cassandra on était ensemble à la fac tu
aurais fait un médecin génial qu'est ce
qui s'est passé je suis parti dans des
circonstances inhabituelles
je suis désolé est pas l'avoir
accompagné il est temps que tu lâches
qu'est ce que tu vas faire ça va
dépendre
c'est le pire cauchemar pour un mec le
trac usa comme ça à ton avis c'est quoi
les pires cauchemars pour une femme
toute petite je voulais déjà être
médecin ça fait quelques temps que je me
dis que j'aimerais peut-être reprendre